Tasha:这怎么可能呢
Tasha: How is that possible?
Tasha:就塞一半呗
Tasha: Just stuff half of it
Shure: OK
Shure: 不行这一半赛出来
Shure: No, stuffing half won't work
Lucia:好他在上面那个盖一打开好了
Lucia: Alright, open the lid on top and it's done
其他人：好他那上面那个盖一打开
Others: Alright, open the lid on top
其他人：好藏完了
Others: Done hiding
其他人：怎么样这个把这个盖
Others: How about this, put this lid
Alice:还有给你
Alice: Here you go
Alice:还藏吗来
Alice: Are we still hiding? Come on
其他人:来好
Others: Come on, okay
其他人:发挥我的想象力
Others: Use your imagination
Lucia:哎呀镜子这会掉
Lucia: Oh no, the mirror will fall
其他人:这不是藏的是贴的
Others: This isn't hidden, it's stuck on
Lucia:可恶哈哈
Lucia: Damn it, haha
其他人：那这个我觉得找到也无所谓
Others: Well, I think finding this doesn't matter
Jake:贴上去的
Jake: It's stuck on
其他人： 总得总得
Others: Always, always
Alice:昨天昨天藏在这一个
Alice: Yesterday, yesterday it was hidden here
其他人：好找的
Others: It's easy to find
Lucia:希望他别掉到后面
Lucia: Hope it doesn't fall to the back
Lucia:拿不出来了就行
Lucia: As long as it can't be taken out
Jake:哦这个还挺挺看到
Jake: Oh, this is still quite visible
Alice:真的没人往桌子底下这放一个吗
Alice: Seriously, no one put one under the table?
Jake:挺容易看到的
Jake: It's pretty easy to see
其他人：桌子地下主要得贴吧
Others: Under the table, you mainly need to stick it
Alice:可以拿个胶带这样反粘着
Alice: You can use some tape and stick it upside down
Lucia:哎呀真掉进去了
Lucia: Oh no, it really fell in
Jake:这个不好
Jake: This is not good
Lucia:嗯哎我的美人指到了
Lucia: Oh, I got my beautiful finger in
Shure: 反粘有点
Shure: Sticking it upside down is a bit
Jake:你可以夹进去
Jake: You can clip it in
Jake:这好夹了
Jake: It's easy to clip in
Jake:这肯定有缝
Jake: There's definitely a gap
Alice:不太好夹吧
Alice: It's not easy to clip, right?
Jake:肯定很有缝吧
Jake: There must be a gap
Jake:没有缝吧
Jake: There's no gap
Jake:这么结实
Jake: It's so solid
Jake:这东西
Jake: This thing
其他人:我好像我藏的地方藏的挺好
Others: I think the place I hid it is pretty good
Shure: 我藏我肚子里一个
Shure: I hid one in my stomach
其他人:哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
Alice:我藏桌子底下一个啊
Alice: I hid one under the table
Alice:就这样吧反正
Alice: Just like that, anyway
Shure: 藏到我裤子里一个
Shure: Hid one in my pants
Lucia:我们光放大厅吗
Lucia: Are we only placing them in the hall?
Lucia:是不是院子也可以放
Lucia: Can we place them in the yard too?
Shure: 你放这里面了啊
Shure: Did you put it in here?
Lucia:这有这个
Lucia: There's this
Shure: 这底下可以可以
Shure: Underneath here is okay
Lucia:大家要想粘也可以用它粘一下
Lucia: If you want to stick, you can use this to stick it
其他人：对吧正好
Others: Right, just perfect
Lucia:就是美纹纸可信
Lucia: It's masking tape, reliable
Lucia:今天要用的那个哦
Lucia: The one we're using today, oh
Alice:可以给我一卷吗
Alice: Can you give me a roll?
Jake:微稍微没那么难找一些
Jake: It's slightly less difficult to find
Alice:古希拉掌管交代的神
Alice: Gushira, the god of delegation
Lucia:古希腊掌管古希腊掌管美纹纸的神
Lucia: The ancient Greek god who oversees beautiful paper.
Jake:也很难找这种
Jake: It's really hard to find this kind.
Lucia:哈哈要吗
Lucia: Haha, do you want it?
Lucia:给你哎呦妈呀
Lucia: Here you go, oh my gosh.
Jake:这就不行
Jake: This won't work.
Alice:没有仪式感一点
Alice: It lacks a bit of ceremony.
Lucia:没有哎呦妈呀哈哈哈
Lucia: Nope, oh my gosh, hahaha.
其他人:就把我藏在那个洗衣机上
Others: Just hide me on top of the washing machine.
其他人:洗衣机上OK
Others: On top of the washing machine, okay.
Lucia:哈不用谢
Lucia: Haha, you're welcome.
Lucia:哈哈这个我应该也就用一卷
Lucia: Haha, I think I'll only use one roll.
其他人:你说啊洗衣机上
Others: You said on the washing machine.
Lucia:可能就差不多了
Lucia: That should be about right.
Lucia:他是就是一买就是五卷
Lucia: He always buys five rolls at a time.
Lucia:但是它很便宜好像才8毛钱
Lucia: But it's really cheap, like 8 cents.
Lucia:还是多少钱
Lucia: Or something like that.
其他人:看我估计长得像是在洗衣机上
Others: I bet I look like I'm on the washing machine.
其他人:其他人:然后我就然后就过去一拿就拿出来
Others: Then I just go and grab it out.
Jake:哪啊哪个洗衣机上
Jake: Where? Which washing machine?
Lucia:而且我们就剪短用一下
Lucia: And then we just cut it short and use it.
Shure: 哈哈哈就是
Shure: Hahaha, exactly.
Katrina: 洗衣机上我藏了一个
Katrina: I hid one on the washing machine.
Jake:其他人:
Jake: Others:
Lucia:我觉得应该也是能用的了的
Lucia: I think it should be usable too.
Jake:哪呢
Jake: Where?
Jake:洗衣机上
Jake: On the washing machine.
Lucia:但我找到了一大包
Lucia: But I found a big pack.
Jake:嘿嘿嘿
Jake: Hehehe.
Shure: 嘿嘿谜底就在谜面上
Shure: Hehe, the answer is in the riddle.
其他人：我反正一拿就拿出来了
Others: Anyway, I just grabbed it out.
Jake:是这个吗
Jake: Is it this one?
其他人:卧槽找到
Others: Whoa, found it.
Shure: 卧槽找到别人
Shure: Whoa, found someone else.
其他人:你哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: You, hahahahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈在
Shure: Hahahahahaha, there.
Lucia:什么呀
Lucia: What?
Alice:什么什么什么
Alice: What, what, what?
Lucia:什么呀
Lucia: What?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:这个很圆这个
Jake: This one is very round.
Shure: 确实特别像
Shure: It really looks like it.
Shure: 那什么呢
Shure: So what is it?
Lucia:花瓶啊底下有一个
Lucia: A vase, there's one underneath.
Alice:哈
Alice: Huh?
其他人：他那个贴桌子底下那个天才般的响
Others: He stuck it under the table, that genius sound.
Alice:那草底下能藏吗
Alice: Can it be hidden under the grass?
Shure: 藏过
Shure: It has been hidden before.
其他人：哎你这新音箱能拆开吗
Alice:这个
Alice: This one.
Lucia:草地下我藏了一个
Lucia: I hid one under the grass.
Alice:这个藏过了吗
Alice: Has this one been hidden?
Shure: 不能
Shure: No, it can't be.
Lucia:你有看到吗
Lucia: Did you see it?
其他人：那就很难找了
Others: Then it will be hard to find.
Alice:没有哦看
Alice: No, look.
Shure: 你要把我音响拆
Shure: Are you going to take apart my speaker?
Alice:看到了
Alice: I saw it.
Shure: 你咋不把我拆了呢
Shure: Why don't you just take me apart?
Lucia:看到了绿色的
Lucia: I saw the green one.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Lucia:这还有
Lucia: There's more here.
Alice:这个底下有吗
Alice: Is there anything underneath this?
Lucia:这个底下好像没有
Lucia: It doesn't seem like there's anything underneath this.
Lucia:但这音箱明天会放在这吗
Lucia: But will this speaker be here tomorrow?
Lucia:有可能会放嗯
Lucia: It might be here, yeah.
Jake:有可能会挪对
Jake: It might be moved, right.
Jake:有意思
Jake: Interesting.
Alice:有意思
Alice: Interesting.
Jake:烤箱能烤好吗我去
Jake: Can the oven bake it well?
Shure: 这叫烤币是吗
Shure: Is this called coin baking?
Lucia:院子里能放吗
Lucia: Can it be placed in the yard?
Jake:院子可以放
Jake: The yard is fine.
Shure: 这个应该没了
Shure: This one should be gone.
Lucia:你的也灭了
Lucia: Yours is out too.
Lucia:OK
Lucia: OK.
Lucia:我的还亮着
Lucia: Mine is still on.
Lucia:耶
Lucia: Yay!
Shure: 当当当当当
Shure: Ta-da-da-da-da!
其他人：来个Zero shot
Others: Let's do a Zero shot.
其他人：Zero shot
Others: Zero shot.
其他人：Zero shot是什么意思
Others: What does zero shot mean?
其他人： 就是你随便训了个模型啊
Others: It means you trained a model randomly.
其他人：这模型呢
Others: And this model...
其他人：测试集完全没见过
Others: Has never seen the test set.
其他人：但他就会
Others: But it just works.
其他人：就是第一遍
Others: On the first try.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Alice:但是充电没有用电快
Alice: But charging it doesn't use electricity that fast.
其他人：非常好的散发
Others: Very well dissipated.
Lucia:放在这烤箱下面
Lucia: Put it under this oven.
Alice:还是低电量
Alice: Still low battery.
其他人：百分之多少
Others: How much percentage?
Alice:百分之三
Alice: Three percent.
Alice:对就是充电没有用
Alice: Yeah, charging didn't work.
Jake:我们先充会电导波数据然后过
Jake: Let's charge it for a while, collect the data, then continue.
Jake:过半个小时把那个QA讨论一下
Jake: After half an hour, let's discuss the QA.
Jake:然后这个明天就存这
Jake: Then we'll save this for tomorrow.
Tasha: 蛋挞要吃掉
Tasha: The egg tarts need to be eaten.
Jake:那就一边讨论QA一边吃蛋挞
Jake: Let's discuss QA while eating the egg tarts.
Tasha: 只有这个是留着的
Tasha: Only this one is left.
Shure: 讨论一下QA
Shure: Let's discuss the QA.
Tasha: 面包给你吗
Tasha: Do you want the bread?
Jake:都给我
Jake: Give it all to me.
Jake:干活了
Jake: Let's get to work.
Lucia:充电宝我刚刚已经摘下来了
Lucia: I just unplugged the power bank.
Lucia:这是我吗
Lucia: Is this me?
Shure: 面包才4下就不行了谢斌竹
Shure: The bread only lasted 4 times, thank you Bin Zhu.
Shure: 这这顶上撒啥了
Shure: What's sprinkled on top of this?
Lucia:哎等一下
Lucia: Wait a second.
Lucia:眼镜我是不是要对停一下然后
Lucia: Should I stop to adjust my glasses, and then...
Jake:你要关掉
Jake: You need to turn it off.
Jake:对你要关掉
Jake: Yes, turn it off.
Jake:关掉就可以啊
Jake: Turn it off and it's fine.
Shure: 眼镜我也要拿下来
Shure: I need to take off my glasses too.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Right?
Jake:你给给我吧好
Jake: Give them to me, okay.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia:等一下哦
Lucia: Wait a moment.
Shure: 应该可以
Shure: It should be fine.
其他人：这是你的吗
Others: Is this yours?
Shure: 啊是我的
Shure: Ah, it's mine.
Katrina: 大概需要多久
Katrina: How long will it take approximately?